de quoi est ce qu'on va parler
aujourd'hui je vous le donne en mille
c'est juste là c'est la nouvelle télé
aux led de lg qui arrivait cette année
c'est la c9 et qui se met en veille
voyez elle a besoin de bouger télé qui
est juste topissime je teste depuis
quelques temps d'été les télés
connectées télé intelligente et celle là
fait partie de mes préférés pour
plusieurs raisons soit déjà au niveau de
la qualité de l'écran au niveau de la
qualité sonore au niveau des options de
ce que vous pouvez faire au niveau de
l'ensemble de l'utilisation m de la
télécommande
je la trouve vachement intéressante je
vais vous expliquer pourquoi
et à la fin contre ou pour me dire en
bas en commentaire ce que vous en pensez
[Musique]
il ya pas mal de critères qui font
qu'une télé est une bonne télé je veux
obtenir un télé parce qu'on dit un
téléviseur quelles sont ces critères à
votre avis selon vous qu'est ce qui fait
qu'un téléviseur est bon qu est ce qui
fait que cette petite bête là pas
remporté le succès du public je vous
laisse nous dire ce que vous en pensez
en bas en commentaire avant qu'on en
parle 1 pourquoi est ce qu'à votre avis
un écran comme celui à une télé ou un
télé comme celui-là peut avoir du succès
à les imiter la pause marque éléments
commentaire et après on fera un petit
tour ensemble pour moi une des premières
choses et non des moindres ça va être le
design comment est-ce que votre écran va
s'intégrer dans votre intérieur alors
ici on a la chance d'avoir un intérieur
qui quand même suffisamment grands pas
parfait parce que vous voyez on a un mur
avec un radiateur qui prend la place
lever de rideau le fixe au mur ce puck
sahara il pour l'instant il y posait là
dessus et ce qui est vachement bien sûr
tour rdc salle vous avez des bords qui
sont extrêmement fins très minimaliste
qui ne prennent pas de place mais ça
c'est vachement important
vous avez un pied qu'il est très discret
qui est très sympa
lorsque vous la regardez comme ça elle
vachement bien intégrés et quand vous la
regardez comme sa garde et elle est
extrêmement fine quasiment invisible
c'est vachement cool un peu plus large
champ là parce que forcément un moment
est produite à pouvoir mettre des choses
mais c'est vrai qu'elle est quand même
très très très très fine
regardez mossala la finesse du truc elle
serait presque invisible c'est juste
hallucinant
donc le design c'est un point essentiel
qui dit si pour le coup extrêmement
minimaliste donc ça j'adore mais il ya
un autre point qui équipera important
parce qu'on parle quand même d'un écran
c'est la qualité de l'écran là vous avez
une dalle oled quatre cas qui est juste
magnifique extrêmement bien calibrée moi
ce que j'aime vraiment sur cet écran là
c'est la justesse des couleurs la clarté
la définition vous avez une précision on
découvre la télé je pars effectivement
d'une télé il ya quelques temps je vous
parle pas l'été que j'ai testé à la télé
que j'avais avant c'est un espèce de
vieux plasma bien manger bon et fort la
changer parce que la qualité plus du
tout la plaie quand vous arrivez sur
quelque chose comme ça vous redécouvrez
complètement la qualité l'image la
pureté la netteté c'est clair c'est
vachement agréable vous avez donc un
écran 4 k u hd 3840 par 2160 pixels avec
une diagonale de 55 pouces ce n'est pas
très bien d'ailleurs
diagonale de 55 pouces soit 139 cm vous
n'avez pas moins de 8 millions de pixels
qui vont ils mettre eux mêmes leur
propre lumière là où vous avez du noir
c'est du noir absolu sq quand on est en
colère
je sais pas si vous le savez mais un
pixel noir c'est un pixel qui est un don
qui ne consomment pas d'énergie une
trace est vachement bien et surtout vous
avez une qualité qui est vraiment
irréprochable 4k cinéma hdr un rendu
exceptionnel la colorimétrie et justin
luminosité est bonne les contrastes sont
bons en terme de rendu de qualité chaud
ça vraiment vraiment top après je ne
sais pas si vous le savez si vous êtes
un expert mais dans le nom des écrans en
tout cas il ya deux grands constructeurs
qui tient leur épingle du jeu qui sont
aujourd'hui les meilleurs vous avez
samsung et vous avez lg les écrans sont
tous extrêmement maîtrisé ça s'est une
fois de plus une vraie réussite
on le voit sur ces écrans comme ça la
qualité hyper impressionnante au point
qui est très cool ce sont les angles de
vision lorsque vous venez vous mettre
sur le côté comme ça
vous voyez vraiment de tous les côtés
vous soyez de ce côté là que vous vous
retrouviez en face que vous vous
retrouviez encore de l'autre côté les
angles de vision sont vraiment très très
juste on voit de tout les côtés et ça
c'est vachement bien
vous pourriez vous dire ok la télé bien
4k usd par contre chez moi j'ai une box
j'ai du full hd j'ai pas du tout de la
4k il ajouté est-ce que je vais pas
tarder en qualité est ce qu'au final
rendu inapte à être pas terrible alors
que j'allais craquer juste incroyable et
qui en plus ont écouté quand même un
certain petit dj mais ça on va pas dans
quelque temps et bien en fait non parce
que le truc vachement bien en termes de
technologie si vous voulez c'est que
votre écran d'apprendre votre four fhd
par exemple full hd et il va vous le
style est juste en 4k il va venir
compenser si vous voulez cette
différence de qualité pour vous proposer
une qualité qui complètement optimale et
ça que vous assurer que c'est encore
effectivement c'est toujours mieux
d'avoir une source
quatre cas si vous regardez un blu ray
par exemple vous aurez toujours la
meilleure qualité ou alors si carrément
vous pouvez avoir une force quatre cas
qui va arriver en streaming netflix
complet ça c'est dash mondial mais
rassurez-vous si la qualité est moindre
set blood la télé de bouloc ce qu'elle
est et là franchement c'est une très
belle réussite mort au terme de
performance je vous passe un peu le truc
vous un processeur alpha 9 de deuxième
génération de l'intelligence
artificielle et à diplo rni
l'apprentissage profond vous avez de
l'intelligence artificielle
a picture qui va en revenir analyser
votre image pour venir complètement
l'optimiser niveau des couleurs du
contraste la luminosité de la saturation
ça vous donner des images plus claires
tout lunettes
en tout cas toujours plus beau toujours
plus optimisée et il n'y a pas du tout
le côté un peu fait qu'on pourrait dire
est qu'en finale cette ia na pas vous
sortir un truc un petit peu what the
fuck un truc un peu faux ben non au
contraire le rendu est vraiment juste
bien calibré de bonne qualité donc voir
une fois de plus une très très belle
maîtrise là dessus vous avez aussi
l'optimisation des images qui se fait
avec dolby vision hdr mais vous avez
aussi du dolby audio parce qu'il ya
aussi de l'intelligence artificielle sur
la partie audio en grosse quoi faire
votre télé elle va venir
optimiser les sons elle va venir
reconnaître une voix une musique pour
mieux détacher la voie pour optimiser la
spatialisation du son envoi optimiser
les fréquences laissées faire un truc
est vraiment bien il ya un rendu qui est
vraiment très très bon et qu'en est il
au niveau de l'audio et d euros vous
avez 40 watts de puissance 2 x 10 watts
pour gérer des haut parleurs un petit
peu ce temps d'apprendre à porter le son
médium grave aigu et vous allez avoir un
caisson de basses de 20 watts
donc là je vous parle effectivement du
côté un petit peu technique au niveau de
l'écran au niveau du son mais là vous
truquez plus intéressant c'est toute la
partie expérience d'utilisation avec
cette petite télécommande notamment je
vous montre ça m'en direz des nouvelles
vous avez donc cette télécommande cette
télécommande qui écoule vous pouvez
utiliser de plusieurs manières ça vous
pouvez cliquer droite up naviguer comme
ça voyez vous avez vos icônes là ça
bouge
vous venez appuyer là soit vous êtes
petite molette et là ça nous ferait
comme une espèce de souris et ça je
trouve ça vachement bien logique à des
personnes qui n'aiment pas moi je trouve
ça assez bien c'est assez marrant au
final perdre et hop c'est je trouve
qu'il est mal calibré je remonte je
remonte up
oui il fait comme je veux c'est vraiment
très très pratique
je viens puis y est sûrement menu chaque
saison là je suis dans ma galerie je
vous montrais côté expérience vraiment
utilisation du logiciel
il faut savoir que là vous avez webos
4.5 vous aident à voir ici la recherche
le tableau de bord de la maison donc là
c'est là où on est et j'appuie de suivre
ils ont retrouvé des petites infos mon
entrée hdmi cm bbox la télé mais sur la
corde à rien si vous êtes du hdmi 2 3 4
vous allez ce qu'il faut les
périphériques domestiques moi j'en ai
aucun de vous pouvez en avoir
ça marche c'est cool donc la voyez par
exemple hop j'ai ici ma petite partie
télé bbox de bouygues telecom alors le
truc qui est assez cool avec ça c'est
qu'en fait d'avoir deux boutons le
bouton ici pour venir allumé la télé est
debout tout aussi pour venir
mais ma boxe une fois j'ai fait les
réglages et qu'il a reconnu qu
aujourd'hui j'appuie il démarre la boxe
et là c'est vraiment hyper pratique
parce que juste avec cette télécommande
je vais pouvoir piloter ma télé n'a box
changer les chaînes sur ma boxe sur matt
est bien le seul point un peu négatif et
lorsque je veux changer les chaînes sur
ma boxe il faut vraiment que je vois
tout de suite en face du décodeur que
c'est très très très directionnelle pour
savoir par contre ce qui est vachement
cool c'est d'avoir une seule
télécommande pour les deux objets et ça
c'est vraiment agréable
bon c'est de voir les applications aux
récentes donc ce que j'ai vu
dernièrement mais deux flics ce qu'elle
faisait youtube et gnagnagna j'ai tout
ici
moi j'aime les raccourcis youtube sur ma
chaîne ici donc je peux cliquer et me
retrouver directement sur youtube puis
la présente je me retrouve sans ma
chaîne youtube voir toutes les infos
toutes mes vidéos tout ça tout ça
bon alors vous n'êtes pas obligé de
mettre noir si vous le faites ce milieu
mais par contre vous pouvez très bien
vous dire ma tâche de m la chaîne
youtube préféré sacile vachement cool ça
marche une fois de plus parfaitement
bien ensuite on continue bon netflix je
vais retrouver mon compte ne fixe avec
toutes les séries toussa toussa toussa
s'écoule ensuite voir rakuten tv au cslc
sport par semaine pas mal de choses et
youtube général prg à une vidéo voyez
j'ai la possibilité se posta lis pas mal
de petites choses
la galerie seront tout à l'heure avec
tous les paysages qui défilent pour
faire de télé une oeuvre d'art ça sur le
site vachement bien navigation internet
photos pour un peu classique musique
l'aja voir lg contente et là j'ai même
amazon avec ça parce que oui et c'est
aussi un des points forts sur cet écran
sur cette télé c'est que vous avez des
assistants personnels vous avez aussi
bien amazon avec ça que google assistant
ici par exemple vous avez le bouton
prennent vidéo voulait s'appuyer
je l'appelais ma zoé avec ça quelle
heure est il alexa enseignement il vise
à 38 et dimanche en france
et lorsque vous les par la google
assistant vous avez ce bouton la voulait
s'appuyer
quelle heure est il il est parti c'est
pratique car vous pouvez poser plein de
questions sur le programme télé sur ce
que vous voulez qu'on le truc est cool
ça l'enjeu bien mais ça ne s'arrête pas
là mais il ya un autre qui est cool
c'est qu'il est compatible apple airplay
depuis si j'ai mon macbook pro je viens
ici tac en aux connexions à mater les lg
web os
et là je dois trouver avec mon écran
poyer qui est là je peux venir utiliser
ma télé pour avoir une copie de mon
écran faire ce que je veux bon bah vous
connaissez l'histoire comme vous
explique comment marche cette
fonctionnalité là mais c'est vachement
cool et 6 ans a en fait qu'on va le
touquet est vraiment intéressant parce
que on sait pas juste une télé c'est pas
juste un écran c'est je dirais une
partie centrale ou de là
lors de votre maison vous allez pouvoir
effectivement dit pliké votre écran de
votre smartphone de votre ordinateur
apple bien évidemment vous allez pouvoir
utiliser un assistant intelligent du
port par la boule de l'assistance et
pourra reparler amazon avec ça vous
allez pouvoir piloter pas mal de choses
vos objets intelligents
lg est bien évidemment vous avez une
fonction télé parce que c'est quand même
la base bonne qualité super écran audio
parfait le truc est vraiment bien bon et
la connectique dans tout ça qu'en est il
alors gardez vous avez du hdmi hdmi ans
où j'ai branché mon câble hdmi hdmi de
l'usb aussi en dessous un slot pci mia
vous retrouvée un peu plus loin encore
du hdmi de l'usb vous avez votre plante
elle ici vous avez aussi une autre et
lan sortie optique enfin voit des trucs
assez complète et l'autre côté vous avez
pas grand chose si ce n'est votre
alimentation secteur qui vient là équipe
à se balader en bas elle a dû 8 ou 5
points 0 du wifi
moi je trouve vraiment bien je suis très
satisfaite at écran pour moi si vous
voulez l'idée c'est pas tendre
d'afficher les specs pour se dire voilà
la télé à la salsa est là çà et là ça
l'idée globale sait gérer
l'environnement c'est le ressenti vous
avez comment vous sentez avec un écran
est ce qu'au final cet écran vous
satisfait parce que la qualité est bonne
ou alors est ce que oui toi ouais je
sais pas il ya un truc king ça ne parle
pas et bien moi ce que j'ai vraiment
apprécié sur cet écran c'est déjà de re
découvrir pas mal de choses en terme de
qualité un truc qui vraiment beau super
qualité des images très belle très net
on a un rendu qui est vraiment
magnifique l'audio et bien alors
effectivement vous pouvez aller encore
plus loin avec de l'audio la semoy il va
falloir installer une barre de sont
inquiets sont externes là vous aurez une
meilleure qualité une meilleure
spatialisation ont déjà commis là ça
fonctionne bien
franchement suffisamment de puissance
sonore mais ce que j'aime beaucoup c'est
aussi l'environnement je trouve que
webos 4.5 fonctionne bien l'expérience
est bonne le fait d'avoir été les
commandes et pouvant naviguer comme ça
pour moi c'est juste c'est juste
magnifique
voilà non moi je trouve ça je trouve ça
vraiment bien une fois de plus très
belle réussite de la part de 2 mg sur
cet écran oled ses 9 55 pouces de 2019
alors c'est une télé qui n'est pas non
plus cadeau cadeaux vous pouvez la
trouver aux alentours de
mille euros d'ailleurs ses intérêts
soient mis un lien en bas dans la
description les tarifs varient toujours
en fonction de la saison des promos
décidé ça mais très honnêtement si vous
avez le budget pour mettre dans un écran
comme ça et si vous voulez un écran vert
avec une très belle qualité en quatre
cahiers hd c'est plus que vous la
recommande et parce que je la trouve
bien et je trouve fina s'intègrent bien
c'est un très bel écran voilà
l'expérience est cool
à vous de nous dire ce que vous en
pensez comment vous la trouvez ce que
vous êtes amoureux des télés amoureuse
amoureux ou amoureuse attention hein
bien des messieurs et des madame je ne
parle pas que des monsieur est ce que
vous êtes amoureux ou amoureuse des
écrans est ce que vous avez une tv 4k
uhd oled ou pas est ce que ça pourrait
potentiellement vous intéresser qu'est
ce que vous pensez de ce modèle là à
vous le dire tout ça en bas en
commentaire et quant à nous on se
retrouve demain voilà les embrassades et
décoder bec take out